Äh, komm, komm noch mal näher Katharina, Katharina.
Das klingt jetzt wie in einem Einen-Kantereizung.
Komm noch mal näher Katharina, komm noch mal wieder zu mir ran, komm mal wieder runter Katharina, Katharina deine Sorgen, interessier mich nur peripher, aufgewachsen, reingekommen, ich hab nur einen Wunsch Katharina, ich hab nur einen Wunsch. Das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, dasgewachsen reingekommen, ich hab nur einen Wunsch, Katharina, dass sie nicht singen an meinem Grab, Katharina, Katharina. Ah, sehr schön. Vielen, vielen Dank. Grossartig. Eine Kooperation von Annemeyn-Kantereit und Nico, der dieses Intro zusammengestellt hat. Vielen Dank. Das ist wieder ein Name, aber unübersichtlich. Annemeyn-Kantereit oder Annemeyn-Niko-Kantereit. Vielleicht kommt der auch so mitten da rein. Genau, wenn ein viertes Mitglied dazukommt, wo wirst du einsortiert? Oder bei ABBA. Also angenommen jetzt Ferdinand, Fabab, Fabba, Af, Babab, wie funktioniert das? Also wenn du ein B bist, definitiv kommst du bei Baba. Mit B kommt man gut rein. Ja, oder Abba, also mit drei B in der Mitte. Das ist auch so das Casting für das fünfte Abba-Mitglied, so wir hätten J für Jabba, wir hätten Kabba, aber jetzt ein Pabba wäre jetzt nicht so gut. Oder fliegt ein B dann dafür raus und sie sind einfach Kabba. Wie war das denn bei TKKG, dass du dann TUSB irgendwie hast, die sind auch nicht mehr die Alten irgendwie. Aber das ist ja Gott sei Dank fiktional, da kann man sich ja ausdenken, wie sie heissen. Gott sei Dank ist TKKG fiktional, also das war das einzige. Eine Erleichterungswelle geht durch Deutschland Gott sei Dank, TKKG, Fiktional und es sind nicht irgendwelche jungen Leute, die meinen Mordfälle, in Klammern, Fragezeichen, aufzulösen. Haben die jemals Mordfälle aufgelöst? Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht genau, was sie gemacht haben, aber ich bin froh, dass sie es tatsächlich nicht gemacht haben. Das ist das einzige, was mich nachts noch schlafen lässt, zu wissen, dass Knete und Kairo und Fleischbällchen... Knete, Kairo, Gustav und Thorsten. Genau, das diene ich auf den... Wurde jemals eine Stadt gesagt? Wo sind die unterwegs? Wiesbaden? Äh, Detmold. Detmold? Sind die in Detmold unterwegs? Okay, und dann sind die dem bösen Igelmörder aufgelauert, der in der Stadt alle Igel umbringt.
Wenn ich so eine Death Metal Band hatte in Deadmold, würde ich mich Deadmold nennen.
Also D-E-A-D-Mold.
Deadmold. Finde ich richtig gut. Deadmold.
Toter Schimmel. Finde ich auch keine schlechte Idee.
Gibt's bestimmt und hört uns bestimmt.
Jemand, der Sänger der Band Deadmold. No Chance, dass ihr nicht Podcast-Ufo hört.
Der Justus, der Sänger von Deadmold. Deadmold aus Deadmold. Das kann schon sein. Meldet euch auf jeden Fall, falls ihr eine Metalband habt und noch einen Namen braucht. Wir können vielleicht unterstützen. Aber Wahnsinn, vielen Dank, Nico, für dieses Intro. Was ein Nonsens-Text. Wir wissen nicht genau, wie stehen wir per se zu ihr. Ja, aber rückblickend jetzt, unsere Erfahrung mit Popmusik zeigt ja eher, dass die Inhalte eher Nonsens sind, also dann einfach deutungsoffen. Man sagt deutungsoffen, man sagt nicht kompletter Bullshit, sondern Interpretationsfreude. Ja, ja, du hast schon recht. Das war auch unser Fehler, glaube ich, immer, dass wir zu viel Sinn machen wollten. Jetzt ist es, glaube ich, einfach gut, Nonsens, Leute schneiden das zusammen und am Ende klingt es einfach wie ein Popsong. Was fällt dir ein, Katharina? Smoke on the water. Was macht er da? Rauch auf. Wie kommt er da hin? Meine Frage ist, wie kommt er da hin? Entschuldigung, meinen Sie Nebel? Ähm, ja. Okay. Also du meinst, fog on the water. Fog on the water. Geht auch, oder? Wir haben noch Zeit, die Aufnahme ist in zehn Minuten, wir haben jetzt noch die Möglichkeit, den Text nochmal zu ändern. Hast du manchmal so Momente, die dir nachts einfallen, wo du dich in Grund und Boden cringest? Und Smog on the Water ist ein so ein Moment für mich. Ich weiss noch, damals unsere Musiklehrerin hat damals ein Musical an den Start bringen wollen. Das war ihr großes Projekt. Kismet. Nee, das war dann was anderes. Das war was anderes, das war immer eine Gesangsklasse, das war schon ein bisschen professionell, das war cooler. Aber unsere Shady-Ass-Schule hat da was aufgeführt. Und zwar, weiß ich nicht mehr, was das für ein belangloses Off-Broadway-Musical, wo die Rechte rumlagen, sagen wir mal so. Die wurden da auf der Strasse in so einer Kiste angeboten, am Strassenrand konnte man sich die Partitur und die Lizenzrechte einfach rausnehmen. Der Regen hat ein bisschen aufgeweicht mittlerweile, aber sie waren verfügbar. Spottbillig, spottbillig, bin ich hinterhergeworfen. Also so liegt es auf der Strasse rum wie Argo DVD. Ja, genau. So und dann kam halt, war es halt so, dass da nur Mädels sich beworben haben und mitmachen wollten. Und es ist auch nicht wie bei amerikanischen Schulen, dass dann da irgendwann so ein Aushang ist, wer die Rollen bekommen hat oder sowas, weil es gibt schlicht zu wenig Schülerinnen und Schüler, die mitmachen wollen an deutschen Schulen. Das heißt, alle, die da Bock hatten, auch nur leicht mal Interesse geäußert haben, wurden quasi reingezerrt und dann kamen die auch nicht mehr raus. Es gibt eher dann so eine Zwangsrekrutierungsliste von Leuten, die eingezogen wurden, obwohl sie gar nicht mitmachen wollen. Nein, ich hab die Rolle. Scheiße, ich bin drin. Scheiße, ich hab die Rolle von Mathilda. Fuck. Eigentlich geil, so ein reversed Highschool Musical, wie alle dann so reingucken auf diesen Aushang und alle, fuck, ich habe die Hauptrolle. Das ist wirklich einfach das absolute Gegenteil von Highschool Musical. Ja, es gibt so ein Draft einfach, das ist so eine Lotterie und dann werden die Leute ausgerufen, die Rolle des Hirten. Nein, nein, nein, nicht die Hirte. Die Mutter mit den Tränen in den Augen, Junge, mein Junge, er muss da mitmachen. Ich bin Herr Hirte, ich bin Hirte zwei. Hirte zwei, das Hirtenmusical. Und jeder weiß, dass Hirte zwei die Hauptrolle ist. Weirdly. Ja, und dann habe ich dann aber Bock gehabt, habe mich dann noch mit einem anderen Kumpel zusammen, haben wir gesagt, komm, wir machen das, auch irgendwie cool, ich fand es eh eine mega spannende Aufgabe. Und dann so, die haben wir schon ein paar Wochen geprobt und wir kamen dann dazu.
Und dann mussten sich alle im Klassenraum verteilen und dann hat die Lehrerin auch Leute gezeigt und dann mussten die A Cappella, einen Song, der ihnen gerade einfällt, singen.
Schrecklich. Und dann die Girls natürlich, keine Ahnung, so Alicia Keys oder Empire State of Mine oder sowas gesungen, mit ihren High Range und diesen Mit Inverzierungen und hier noch was und dann noch ein Schlenker und so. Und dann hat sie mir für mich gezeigt und ich habe Smoke on the Water geträllert, aber halt Smoke on the Water. So, weißt du, from the top of your head sollst du jetzt einen Song singen. Wie gemein, alles daran ist so scheiße. Wie geht es dann weiter? Und du hast nicht immer einen düm, düm, düm, hast du nicht immer gemein. Niemand im Raum. Niemand im Raum hat Sam Dündin. Das ist fast eine Selbstbeherrschungsprobe, wenn niemand, wenn du in einem vollbesetzten Raum Smoke on the water. Irgendjemand wird, ne, ne, ne.
Das ist so, und ich denke da einmal die Woche dran und es ist so schrecklich, weil es fällt mir kein anderer Song ein.
Ich kenne nicht mal, ich weiß nicht mehr, wie es weitergeht.
The Fire in the Sky, I don't know, shit.
The Fire in the Sky.
Oh Gott, ey, dann singe ich da Smoke on the Water, irgendwas und dann musst du das A Cappella singen und dann erst mal mir fällt, wenn mich jemand fragt, nenn mir drei Songs, fällt mir eh schon keine drei Songs ein. Wenn mich jemand fragt, was dein Lieblingsfilm, habe ich das Gefühl, in meinem Leben jemals habe ich Shrek und Shrek zwei und ich habe beide noch nicht gesehen. Da finde ich aber gut, vor allem welche Fähigkeit genau soll das abrufen, weil in einem Musical muss man relativ selten einfach improvisiert, spontan ein neues Lied anfangen.
Ich glaube, es ist dieser Teil, den es ja beim Theater häufig gibt, dieses Voreinander, sich nackt ausziehen, Vertrauens bilden, Gruppen bilden, Grüppchen bilden.
Eigentlich muss man sich durchcringen, das ist ja eigentlich die Aufgabe. Wir cringen jetzt gemeinsam und dann sind wir ein unveränderliches Band. Dann reisst uns nichts mehr auseinander.
Genau, bis das Publikum zum ersten Mal sieht, was wir auf die Beine gestellt haben und die dann auch cringen. Das war, das finde ich sehr unangenehm. Und dann auch Smoke on the Water, auch unangenehme Unk- Was sagt das über mich aus? Die zeigt auf mich und ich singe Smoke on the Water. Sorry Stefan, hallo. Ich will an mir rütteln und sagen, hast du einen Schaden und dann haue ich mir so einmal durchs Gesicht, wach auf.
Wenn du dich jetzt noch mal in diese Situation begeben könntest, welchen Song würdest du rückblickend lieber singen, wo du sagst, das ist der beste Song?
Also nur für alle Hörer und Hörer, die vielleicht jemals auch in so einer Situation kommen, die jetzt sagen, ich habe Bock in einem Musical zu singen, welchen Song kann man sich immer in den Köcher stecken, dass man den immer bereit hat, in der Gesäßtasche, dass man immer sagen kann, zur Not.
Ja, vor allem, es fängt ja schon da an, wo sollte man, genau, also man sollte ja irgendwie etwas, vielleicht etwas singen, was nicht Melodie, ähm, Instrumental-lastig ist.
Ja.
Jetzt, der nächste Song, der mir gerade einfiel, also meines, geh nochmal zurück in die Zeit, dachte ich, I got a feeling. Es ist wieder der gleiche Fehler. Ich mache den gleichen Fehler wieder. Weil es ist eine Gesangspause, alle denken sich, es ist zu ruhig die Situation, es ist viel zu awkward, das jetzt dann mitzusingen. Den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den Freiheit wohl grenzenlos sein. Alle Ängste, alle Sorgen, sagt man, liegen darunter verborgen und dann. Das war eine Zeit, wo Fliegen noch richtig besonders war, wo man gesagt hat, wow, wir sind über den Wolken das erste Mal ever. Ja, heute wäre die Stimmung eine andere. Ich habe keine Sorgen. Heute wäre die Stimmung eher, über den Wolken, will ich dann auch mal endlich am Ziel ankommen, danke. So, das wäre eher die Stimmung, so man, wir hatten ja die Idee Vollnarkose und dann alle Reihen einfach, Menschenhaufen, voll narkotisierter Menschenhaufen, ich weiß nicht, ob das mittlerweile irgendjemand angemacht hat. Warum kam darauf keine Reaktion? Null. Kein Flieger, kein Pilot, kein Stewardess hat mal gesagt, joa. Ich will so, ganz viele Menschen sollen in den gleichen Fliegern wie heute unter Narkose, dann laufen noch zwei Anästhesisten, wie beim Film Prometheus. Die Wiese bei Whack-a-Mole, immer wenn jemand aufwacht, wird der sofort wieder weggespritzt. Einfach wenn der so, hör wo bin, direkt wieder eine Spritze. Jeder hat zwei Spritzen, in jeder Hand eine Spritze und läuft so durch und muss immer so gucken, wer wird wach. Und dann wird wieder weggekommen. Wenn wie einer auch nur leicht leicht bewegt. Zack, einzucken und zack, hast du eine Spritze im Arm direkt wieder.
Noch geiler und ein bisschen dystopischer noch wäre so eine Drohne, die so rumfliegt.
Oh ja.
Die immer, wenn sie so ein Bewegungs... die immer so rumreißt.
Ja, oder immer so rote Lichter durch den Raum wandern.
Wenn du dich bewegst, zack, krasst du wieder so eine Spritze im Arm.
Gott, ist das die Zukunft...
Wildly dystopisch.
Ist das die Zukunft, auf die wir zusteuern, Stefan Tietze? Naja, ist das wirklich so düster gerade? Ich wollte ja nur eine coole neue Art des Fliegens, wir kriegen den ganzen Reisestress nicht mit, ich schlafe durch, wache in L.A. auf und denke mir, yippie, yay, yay. So, und jetzt machen wir das so. Denkst du? Aber du sprichst es nicht aus. Was wir ja jetzt gemacht haben daraus, ist so eine komische, dystopische Horrorvorstellung, weil du sagst, da läuft schon Spritzenmann rum, wenn du eine Spritze in den Armen jagen. Naja, du willst ja nicht dann, der einzige sein, der auf der Hälfte der Strecke dann aufwacht, umringt von scheinbar Leichen, weil man da alleine aufwacht. Kurz eine Minute brauchst, um zu checken, wo du bist, schreist wie am Spieß, versuchst dich zur Orientierung kurz am Fenster zu orientieren. Keine Chance, Grönland, vergiss es. Du bist völlig desorientiert. Es ist keine Ahnung, wo du bist. Naja, wenn du weisst, Grönland, bist du nicht so desorientiert. Ah! Naja, gut. Ich meine, reicht dir das, Grönland? Würdest du Grönland erkennen von der Luft aus? Ja, aber so lustig, weil jetzt bei TikTok, Instagram und so, diese ganzen Reels, da gibt es jetzt so viele Leute, die rumlaufen und sagen, ihr kriegt zehn Euro, wenn ihr drei Länder mit G sagt. Und dann sagt einer Grönland und sie sagt, das ist kein Land, sondern Schnitt und dann sieht man andere Leute, die da mitmachen. Und ich denke mir, und das sieht man ja häufig, diesen Trend. 15 Minuten Fame für jeden. Das war mein Moment.
Aber ich dachte, wer ist sie, dass sie alle Länder mit G kennt?
Ja.
Weil diese Menschen, die diese Fragen stellen, die den Leuten 10 Euro geben, wissen ja alle Länder.
Also ich finde, das ist beeindruckend.
Die wissen ja alles.
Das ist krass.
Woher wissen die Leute, die diese Fragen stellen, alles?
MF, viele damit V.
Venezuela, Venedig, Veru.
Ist keine Stadt, ist kein Land. Und Wamboland.
Wamboland ist erst seit 86 anerkannt.
Ja, es ist schwierig. Und was ist Monaco eigentlich?
Ist das ein Fürstentum?
Stadtland, Fürstentum.
Stadtland?
Stadtland, Fluss und Fürstentum. Alles auf einmal einfach drin. Das viel. Ich meine, früher im Mittelalter war alles so groß wie Monaco, so winzig kleine Flecken, wo du gesagt hast, da komme ich her und dann bist du woanders und dann ist alles wieder anders. Im Prinzip stimmt, alles war wie Monaco, es waren kleine Fürstentümer, in denen extrem reich viele Yachten und dann wird einmal pro Jahr ein Formel-1-Rennen gefahren. Ich habe mal gehört, im Mittelalter gab es mehr Yachten als Menschen, weil da so viele Yachten gebaut wurden, dass es tatsächlich einfacher war, die Menschen in Yachten leben zu lassen, als in Häusern. Habe ich gehört. Wo denn? Wo hörst du deine Sachen denn? Auf dem YouTube-Kanal, zu einem Geschichtskanal. Yachten? Der hat es erzählt. Der meinte auch, dass es früher keine Treppen gab und die Menschen sich immer so runterfallen lassen mussten. Also wenn die irgendwie, also du nimmst so eine Burg und dann bist du oben auf der Burg und sagst, kommst du runter, okay. Und dann musst du einfach die Wand runterfallen. Und dann musst du dich aufstehen, abputzen. Und dann gezeigt, das war völlig normal, dass wenn du einfach irgendwie ein Haus mit zwei Stöcken, irgendwie so einen Kornspeicher oder so und dann kletterst du da hoch und dann musst du dich einfach runterfallen lassen, weil es gab noch keine Treppen. Ja, aber du kannst ja versuchen, zumindest runter zu klettern. Naja, haben die nicht gemacht. Für dich ist es selbstverständlich, aber damals, im Mittelalter, haben die gesagt, hoffentlich sterbe ich nicht und runtergesprungen. Wie sind sie hochgekommen? Hochgeklettert. Da haben sie geklettert, ja. Und ansonsten runtergefallen. Und irgendjemand hat gesagt, leider das ist echt nicht gut, weil das meiste geht kaputt, die meisten Leute sterben einfach und deswegen lassen sie eine Treppe bauen. Und dann wurde eine Treppe gebaut. Und da zischen gab es nichts, es direkt die Treppe. Die Treppe, ja. Direkt die Treppe und dann noch mal viele Johannit später die Rolltreppe und seitdem ist Schluss. Ich finde das so doof mit dem das Rad ist die wichtigste Erfindung. Was gab es davor? Nur Schlitten oder was? Alles mit Schlitten? Und dann kam direkt das Rad, also es war ja nicht, mir kann niemand erzählen, das Rad wurde erfunden. Nee, erst mal Viereck, Viereck, Sechseck, Achteck und dann irgendwann sagt man, lass uns die Ecken ganz weg machen, lass uns einen Kreis machen. Nee, aber es gab ja nie ein Viereck, ne? Ich verstehe den Gag, ich mag den Gag. Es gab ja nie ein Viereck. Sagst du jetzt wirklich?
Nee, man hat nie, These, man hat nie einen Würfel unter den Karren gespannt, weil man dachte, wow, das ist jetzt die beste Idee. Aber die haben schon rum experimentiert hier gesagt. Karren, das ist super. Lass uns, wie wäre es mit einem Parallelogramm? Hexogramm. Also Chef, ich habe hier acht verschiedene geometrische Formen. Kegel, Zylinder, lass uns gucken, was passt. Und am Ende kam jemand auf Kreis. Ich glaube das nicht. Ich glaube das nicht. Wie gesagt, es ist alles in diesem Historien-YouTube-Video. Aber schon krass, ne? Also ich bin, weil ich letztens meinen Ausstieg verpasst, bin an Köln vorbeigefahren, in dem Moment der geistigen Umnachtung, was wirklich so das Dümmste ist, was du machen kannst. Oh Gott, so unbefriedigend, weil du ... Und je früher es dir auffällt, desto schlimmer ist, dass du, du siehst ja quasi die Strecke, die du gleich wieder zurückfahren musst, siehst du ja. Vor allem das Ding war, ich schaue aus dem Fenster, denke, ach, das ist doch Köln, okay, pack mein Zeug zusammen, nehm Rucksack, bin schon bereit und merke, der hält nicht an. Das ist schon die Ausfahrt aus Köln, fuck, wir fahren raus. Vor allem jetzt muss man zu sagen, dass Köln wirklich der einfachst zu erkennendste Bahnhof ist, weil du über den Rhein ankommst, den Dom, in die Fresse geschmissen wird, du super lange auch immer auf dieser Zug auf der Hohenzollernbrücke noch stehst. Das war nicht die Schuld von Köln. Köln macht alles, um dich reinzuwinken, um wirklich dich da hinzubringen. Und dann fährst du weiter und dann aber, du kennst mich wahrscheinlich als recht ruhigen und gefassten Menschen, aber in solchen Momenten volles Melodrama. Volles Melodrama, ich schaue auf mein Handy, ich werfe die Hände in die Höhe, nein, oh nein, guck nochmal rum, die Beschilderung. Im Ruhrabteil. Ja, alles ein bisschen leiser, sag ich mal, stummfilm. Wie viel Drama kann man haben? Eine Menge, eine Menge, stummfilm. So, und dann drücke ich ich meinen Kopf gegen die Lehne von dem vorderen Sitz, wirklich mit so einem ... Wirklich mein ganzer Körperspiel. Wirklich um ... Ich weiß gar nicht warum, aber einfach ... Warte, ich mach kurz Stummfilm-Musik an, und dann muss man sich vorstellen, wie Florentin sich dann die Arme in die Luft wirft. Beschreib, wie du dich aufregst. Hände in die Höhe, oh nein, Köln-Ausfahrt. Da kommt so eine Texttafel. Köln-Ausfahrt. Florentin hat die Bahnausfahrt verpasst. Hände in die Höhe, mit beiden Händen klammer ich mich ans Smartphone, wetternd die Faust zum Himmel, umschauen. Warum geht denn jetzt hier das Internet nicht? Ich schau mich um, schau auf die Beschilderung, lass den Rucksack neben mir zu Boden sacken. Die Sitznachbarin bewegt ihren Mund, Texttafel, hier ist eigentlich das Ruheabteil. Zwei Reihen vorher besorgt, Mensch, was ist denn mit dem? Da muss ja was Schlimmes passiert sein. Ich glaube, ich will einfach allen anderen zeigen, dass das nicht geplant war, sondern dass das jetzt schlecht gelaufen ist. Willst du auch ein bisschen Lacher haben dann? Nein, ich will Mitleid, ich will bemitleidet werden, ich will sagen, Mensch, dem geht's richtig schlecht und ich möchte mein Leid dem Kosmos zu Gehör verfügbar zu stellen. Das passt nicht zu dem, wie ich dich kennengelernt habe. Ich weiß, und das ist nur in Extremsituationen so, wo ich dann wirklich auch wirklich ein komplettes Theaterstück aufführe, komplettes Kismet, komplette Drama, nochmal extra nochmal mit dem Fuss, mit dem Knie, gegen den Sitz, damit es mir auch körperlich wehtut, absolutes Melodrama, absolut erbärmlich. Naja, ich verstehe es, normalerweise willst du ja, würde ich jetzt mal behaupten, möglichst wenig Interaktion mit Leuten haben, aber dieses Melodrama sorgt ja dafür, dass Leute sagen, kann ich ihnen helfen, was ist denn bei ihm los und so, Also du ziehst ja sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit auf dich, was du normalerweise komplett nicht willst beim Zugfahren. Super interessant. Ja, absolut. Hast du noch eine andere Situation? Das ist natürlich auch die Frage, wessen Aufmerksamkeit ich haben will, weil teilweise aufwendig, weil mein Fahrrad ist natürlich kaputt, das ich mir vor kurzem gekauft habe. Wenn da irgendwie mitten in der Fahrt die Kette... Wer ist denn mal Probe gefahren? Wenn da die Kette rausspringt und so, dann auch Au, au, au, Schienbein und so und dann auch wirklich riesen Melodrama ist ganz unangenehm. Das gefällt mir, diese Phase, wenn jetzt so eine Melodrama-Fase von Florentin kommt, ah wie geil. Das wäre mir richtig unangenehm, das glaube ich, wirklich mein Tiefpunkt. Ich sollte auch ein bisschen Drama dir abgeben manchmal.
Ja?
Weil ich bin schon dramatisch. Ja, okay. Ja. Aber deswegen verstehe ich, das finde ich sehr gut, dass du jetzt auch in so eine Richtung gehst. Ein bisschen viel Hände in die Luft und ein bisschen Probleme. Und dann kam ich an, beim nächsten Bahnhof musste wieder umsteigen, natürlich den U-Turn of Shame, aber dann habe ich dort Rolltreppen gesehen. Und da dachte ich mir, wir leben schon in einer geilen Zeit, wo selbstverständlich ist, dass wir nicht die Treppen gehen müssen. Nein. Es gab Zeiten, da gab es keine Treppen und wir denken uns, also selbst die schäbigsten Bahnhöfe, das war jetzt Frankfurt, selbst die Du musst sie nicht nennen. Unbedrängt genannt. Unbedrängt beleidigt. Selbst die haben Rolltreppen, wo es selbstverständlich, man für null Euro, also du musst ja nicht mal einen Euro reinwerfen oder so. Also ich würde dafür zahlen. Für Rolltreppen? Musst du aber nicht, sondern du fährst einfach runter mit diesem riesigen Stahlwuchtgerät, mit dieser riesigen Maulwurfmaschine. Bisschen viel Lärm für nichts, ne ich. Es ist nicht viel, aber es ist schon, genau, es ist Wahnsinn, dass wir so viel Aufwand dafür betreiben können, um da runterzufahren. Drei Meter Höhe legst du zurück und dafür baust du so einen Kohle schluckenden Stahldampfer. Vor allem, wenn du mal siehst, die sind ja andauernd kaputt, auch super high maintenance, super pflegeintensiv. Ja, super komplex auch, super schwierig. Und dann guckt man Leuten dazu, wenn die die Sticheln oft daneben und guckt mir, guckt gespannt, so wie das da drinnen aussieht, wenn die das dann aufbauen. Was da drunter für ein Mechanismus ist, unglaublich, super viel Zahnräder. Dafür, dass wir nicht 20 Schritte gehen müssen, sondern stehen bleiben können. Ja, zweieinhalb Höhenmeter zurücklegen. Und da dachte ich mir, ach nee, eigentlich geht's schon gut.
Und dann war ich wieder ein bisschen beruhigt.
Aber warum muss man dafür nicht zahlen,
aber für Toiletten muss man zahlen, so Serways-Toiletten?
Ja, gute Frage, so warum ist das nicht ...
Weil das denn Menschen, ich muss mich entlehren, jetzt,
dann würde ich doch bitten, jetzt ist kein Geld für zu bezahlen.
Gut, aber dann ist man einfach auf superdreckigen Toiletten.
Meinst du, man kann da mit Bahnhofsbetreibern reden,
kann sagen, pass auf, wir zahlen für Rollutreppen, dafür nicht mehr für Toiletten.
Aber du bestrafst ja Leute, die nicht die Treppen hochgehen können, ältere Leute.
Ja.
Ja, gut, aber lieber ältere Leute bestrafen oder Leute, die sich nicht leisten können, aufs Klo zu gehen.
Also, irgendjemand musst du bestrafen, das ist ja, aber interessant. Ich bin neulich, und das war eine irre Erfahrung, ich stehe am Bahnsteig und wie ich es immer mache, bin zehn Minuten vor Abfahrt da, pünktlich, vielleicht sogar eine Viertelstunde, lass es zwanzig Minuten gewesen sein. Ich bin gern früh da, bin vorbereitet, stehe schon am richtigen Gleisabschnitt und so weiter, stehe da, habe mein Essen dabei, mein Trinken dabei, Playlist auf den Ohren, ich bin ready für die Fahrt. Und dann kommt eine Durchsage, und die werde ich nie vergessen und die Reaktion auch nicht. Ja, hi, wir können es nicht glauben, liebes Gleis, hi, Gleis acht, wir können es nicht glauben, aber der Zug ist vor einer halben Stunde schon losgefahren. Was? Also er war nicht so schockiert, aber ihm war das so peinlich zu erzählen, dieser Stimme, dieser ominösen Stimme am Berliner Bahnhof. Der Zug ist zu früh losgefahren. Viele Fragen in meinem Kopf. Ja, aber warum kann ich einmal wieder zurückkommen?
Ja, wie weit ist er schon? Vollbremsung?
Das ist ja nicht so schlimm, dachte ich mir.
Komm mal zurück.
Also ...
Meinst du, das ist eine Ausrede?
Dafür, dass der Zug ausgefallen ist und die einfach sagen,
das können wir jetzt nicht sagen.
Nee, das Lustige war, dass wir den dann eingeholt haben. Der neue Zug dann hat den eingeholt. Weil dann war, der ist dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ob ich eine Baustelle oder so was stehen geblieben. Der ist ein bisschen zu voreilig, hab ich das Gefühl. Der ist ein bisschen zu schnell gefahren. Und die Leute, die den erwischt haben, aus ominösen Gründen, weil die noch eher am Gleis stehen als ich. Das ist ja das Beste. Der ist irgendwie eine 40 Minuten vor geplanter Abfahrtzeit losgefahren. Wie das passieren kann, ist mir schon ein Rätsel. Alles daran war merkwürdig, ich war ultrasauer. Und alle waren am Gleis, waren halt entsetzt. Und das ist ja wirklich, da kommt ja Deutschland zusammen. Deutschland ist ja eher ein Land, wo man nicht mit Fremden interagiert, nicht wie in den USA, wo man sich die ganze Zeit anspricht und sowas, eine sehr offene, so eine direkte, direktere Sprachkultur hat, in Deutschland ist ja eher jeder für sich, aber was die Deutschen total zusammenschweißt, ist Ärger über die Bahn. Ja, und das war ja auch noch eine lustige Situation, was dazu geführt hat, dass die einen 50 Prozent sich entschieden haben, wir regen uns jetzt tierisch auf, schmeissen unsere Koffer auf den Boden und den Florentin machen. Melodramatisches auf die Knie fallen und gehen Himmel schreien. Wenn man in Frankfurt sagt, den Florentin machen. Und die anderen haben sich kaputt gelacht, weil der Bahn jetzt auch noch einfällt, ah, wir können noch einen anderen Fehler machen als zu spät, wir können noch zu früh abfahren. Es gibt noch einen weiteren Fehler, den wir falsch machen. Und diesen Witz habe ich bestimmt
auf der Bahnfahrt im Bordbistro
schon, ich habe den drei, vier Mal gemacht.
Ah, jetzt ist der Bahn noch aufgefallen, wir können noch zu früh
losfahren. Sie pendeln sich ein.
Ich habe so viel Lacher bekommen, das erste
Mal, als ich den laut an meinem
Platz dann erzählt habe, diesen Witz,
dass ich den so oft wiederholt habe,
wie so ein Programm, was ich so in jedem Wagen noch mal
gemacht habe. So eine komplette Comedy-Tour, einmal durch den Waggon. Ich hatte so viel Spaß. Und das war dann so ein, es war so merkwürdig halt diese ganze Bahnfahrt, weil halt alle Gags auf den Lippen hatten, weil sich halt alle so verbrüdert haben. Also der ganze Waggon war so eine Verbrüderung, dieser neue, in dem man dann eigentlich ging ist, gemeinsam. Und dadurch haben halt alle in so einer Lautstärke mit ihren Witznachbarn gesprochen, dass halt alle ringsrum auch noch den Witz hören. Ich finde das so lustig, wenn das passiert. Das ist wirklich fantastisch. Ich denke auch an den Zugführer von dem Zug, der zu früh losgefahren ist, der so guckt in seinem Zug und da sitzen so zwei Leute drin. Sie denkt, warum will denn keiner bei mir mitfahren?
Wollt ihr denn wenigstens einen Kaffee haben?
Also weil wir haben zwölf Wagons und jetzt sind zwei Leute da.
Na, dann fahren wir los.
Ja, dann.
Hat jemand so früh die Trillerpfeife gepfiffen?
Irgendwann, du bist so früh losgegangen. Ach so, ich dachte schon, dass keiner mehr mit mir mitfahren will. Nee, das ist viel schlimmer, was du gemacht hast. Du bist ja zu früh losfahren. Das stimmt, vielleicht auch ungeduld, einfach so. Scherz, wo du sitzt in so einem IC und denkst, komm jetzt, komm Und dann dachte ich mir, vielleicht können die nicht zurückfahren.
Vielleicht können Züge nicht rückwärts fahren.
Ja, aber haben die nicht so eine Steilkurve, wo die dann so hoch und dann so wieder zurückfahren können?
Ja, ich glaube, da müsstest du halt nur mitten
auf der Strecke aussteigen und einmal
entlanglaufen und hinten wieder einsteigen.
Es war so merkwürdig.
Es ist wirklich komisch.
Zu früh losfahren. Ich glaube,
das haben die extra gemacht, weil keine Ahnung, vielleicht ist da vor ein Zug ausgefallen und dann fuhren zwei nur mit einem dreiviertel Stunden Abstand danach aus Berlin Richtung Köln und ich glaube, die haben einen halt davon früher abfahren lassen, um halt alle Leute, die an den Bahnsteigen stehen, auf der Strecke nach Köln wollen oder Richtung Köln wollen, ja, einen Zug zu bieten, der früher wegfährt, keine Ahnung. Ich dachte, es ist ein abgegattertes Spiel, das kann auch kein Fehler sein, das kann noch wirklich kein Fehler sein. Vor allem, dass der so früh auch schon da ist, also das Team an Bord. Ich muss mir das nochmal angucken, also ob da nicht, nee, ich gucke da nochmal rein. Wie willst du da nochmal rein? Ob da nicht nochmal, nee, ich gehe da nochmal in die App rein. Wie in die App rein? In den Navigator rein, schau ich mir das noch mal genau an, was da passiert ist.
Gibt es da ein Archiv? Es gibt ein Archiv, ja, es gibt das große Bahnarchiv, wo du noch mal reingehen kannst, mit allen Flyern, noch mal mit allen verschiedenen Packungen von dem Bordbistro, alles ist da. Wahnsinn. Alles kannst du da machen. Das war Wahnsinn, der absolute Wahnsinn. Jetzt fährt die Bahn noch zu früh los. Leute, nehmt euch in Acht. Natürlich, Bahnhass verbindet Deutsche, aber was natürlich Deutsche auch verbindet, ist natürlich Übernahme. Ja, ihr habt das natürlich mitbekommen. Das Subreddit TEE sollte übernommen werden, subtil, und jetzt ist es tatsächlich gelungen. Es wurde erfolgreich übernommen. Ich bin so stolz auf euch, so stolz auf euch, nicht in Gänze, weil es war, es wurde zum Teil eine feindliche Übernahme. Das wollten wir nicht, das wollten wir nicht mit Ausrufe zeichnen. Stellt sich raus, wenn man einfach einen unkontrollierten Mob an Zuhörern loslässt, dass man dann gar nicht mehr so viel Kontrolle darüber hat. Hm, naja. Aber wir waren sogar dann irgendwann mit sehr vielen Upvotes, war diese Aktionen besprochen worden in anderen Reddits. Genau, im Deutschland-Reddit. Im Deutschland-Reddit wurde gesagt. Wo dieser Erfolg gefeiert wird, endlich mal wieder eine Invasion, die funktioniert hat, endlich mal langfristig wieder Gebietsgewinne, da kann man sich gemeinsam freuen auf Slash.de, wo man sagt, ja, TEE gehört uns. Vor allem im Deutschland Reddit war ja erst lange nicht mehr viel zu feiern. Das stimmt, ja. Weder irgendwie erfolgreiche Übernahmen von Ländern, noch Eurovision Song Contest, noch WM oder sowas. Richtig, ich glaube Deutschland jetzt gebraucht nach dem ESC, dass man jetzt mal wieder was zu feiern hat. Es ist mittlerweile offiziell, denn die Beschreibung des Subreddits lautet mittlerweile This Subreddit is dedicated to the love of German tea. Mit ein paar, ich gebe mal ein paar Impressionen. Wir haben hier bewertet meine neue 0,5-Tasse fürs Büro. Wir haben mal Tee aus einer Geige gemacht. Wo bestellt man in Deutschland am besten Chemun, Bio-Schwarz-Tee von Aldi, die Zulassung von Stevia ist das Schlimmste, was Früchtetees je passieren konnte. Also ihr seht, mittlerweile Amtssprache, klassisches Deutsch, Hochdeutsch, Themen. Ja, also Stammtischhaftigkeit, so eine, auch in dieser Vehemenz, ist das Schlimmste, was uns jemals passiert ist. Also da ist schon jetzt eine Menge, ja, Deutschheit drin. Auf jeden Fall, also mittlerweile ist alles eingedeutscht und ich glaube, wir konnten die T-Shirt-Fans erfolgreich verdrängen. Aber es war sehr süss und auch ein bisschen traurig, damit anzugucken, wie dieser T-Shirt-Fan ein amerikanischer Der letzte, alleine auf seiner Insel, der noch verteidigt hat. Der Moderator, der wurde einfach verdrängt. Und irgendwann hat er gesagt, ja gut, dann ist es jetzt halt ein T-Reddit, I guess. Weil viele Leute auch auf Deutsch geschrieben haben. Wir haben ja noch letzte Woche besprochen, dass der sich wieder gesetzt hat, hat gesagt, Leute, das ist ein englisches Subreddit für T-Shirt-Liebhaber und der musste aufgeben, wurde über, der Bearhack hat funktioniert, wir haben das ganze Ding übernommen und jetzt ist natürlich die Ich dachte halt, Bearhack, ich hab so Winnie-Pooh-mässig gedacht. Ja. Es war aber der Revenant, es war der Revenant Bearhack, also so von der Auf der Bearhack-Skala eher in Richtung Oscar verdächtig. Das stimmt. Es war der Inyaritu Berhack mehr als der so ein Paddington-artiger. Jetzt stellt sich natürlich diese historisch sehr schwere Frage Putsch und was jetzt? Putsch und was danach? Und damit herzlich willkommen in der neuen Rubrik Putsch und was dann? Wo wir Lifestyle-Tipps geben, für was man nach einem erfolgreichen Putsch macht.
Ihr habt erfolgreich einen Putsch gemacht, militärisch oder ziviler Art, das bleibt euch überlassen. Wie geht's jetzt weiter? Schritt zwei, wir sind hier, um heute alles zu besprechen. Putsch, Weiterführung, was sind die nächsten Schritte, wie macht man das meiste aus seinem Putsch? Heute bei uns im Studio Stefan Tietze. Genau, und heute ist die Frage Putsch und was nun? Und dafür, ja genau, nehmen wir uns jetzt immer das Beispiel dieses Subreddits. Wir haben es jetzt geschafft, diesen sehr, diesen schäbigen T-Shirt-artigen. Wurden aus dem Fenster geworfen, in den Burggraben. Genau, und haben da jetzt einen T-Subreddit. Ich finde, jetzt ist es erstmal wichtig, dem Leben einzuhauchen. Also wir haben noch ein paar so Karteileichen rumliegen. Also Leute, die sich für meinen Geschmack noch ein bisschen zu sehr für T-Shirts interessieren. Die müssen entweder raus, feindlich rausgeschmissen werden, oder man erzieht die um zu einer T-Liebe. Also willst du dass die T-Shirt-Liebe austreiben? Also willst du, dass sie sich sozusagen bekennen, dass sie vom T-Shirt abschwören, von der alten Regierung? Also man muss mal, kann man vielleicht auch so Zoom-Gespräche oder so was dann mit denen planen, also ich würde die alle anschreiben, jetzt die neuen Moderatoren, die jetzt die alten langsam auch mal weg, also mal hinten rüberfallen lassen.
Und dann kann man mal so Zoom-Gespräche machen, wo man mal fragt, wie sehr sie sich eigentlich für Tee interessieren. Und wenn rauskommt, nee, es ist primär noch ein T-Shirt-Interesse da, dann muss man vielleicht die Leute aus diesem Reddit bannen. Das ist eine Möglichkeit, ich werfe eine zweite Möglichkeit in den Raum, ein zweiter Putsch, Dass zum Beispiel jetzt die Liebhaber des Buchstabens T jetzt sozusagen aus der Putschlawine heraus quasi sozusagen sich abspalten und den Putsch nochmal wegputschen. Die Unordnung, die Re-Revolution, die gerade noch herrscht, nutzen für ihre T-Liebhaber. Ja, die jetzt sagen, T, welcher Font ist das Beste, kleines T versuses Tee, ich glaube, da gibt es viel zu besprechen, kann man da nicht noch was machen, um da vielleicht jetzt diese neu eingesetzte Regierung, die noch nicht wirklich sattelfest ist, direkt wieder wegputschen. Natürlich Gefahr, dass dann auch wieder die T-Shirt-Leute kommen, um dieses Machtvakuum erneut zu füllen. Das könnte natürlich auch passieren. Und Tim Ernst Eberhardt, der halt nun mal der Polizeipräsident von Berlin, der dann sagt, nee, das ist mein Subway, da gibt es vielleicht auch noch ein paar kleine Splittergruppen, so ein Mann-Armeen, die auch noch ankamen und sagen, weil diese Unordnung, die gerade herrscht, muss man ja sagen, es herrscht gerade auch so ein bisschen so ein Postputsch-Chaos. Man findet sich gerade, ja, das ist richtig. Und da muss man sich jetzt finden. Ich bin auch nicht unbedingt happy mit dem visuellen Weg, den der Subreddite eingeschlagen hat. Hier hat man sich nämlich auf die Pinguine von Madagaskar geeinigt. Und da habe ich ein paar Fragen. Das Hintergrundbild, ja. Die in der Tat Tee trinken, das stimmt? Ja, aber gut. Trotzdem ist meine Frage, warum? Aber ich glaube, das war doch so ein alter Gag, so ein, ja jetzt viel Spaß mit eurem Scheiß. Der alte Moderator hat das nämlich gemacht. Der hat nämlich den Röder aufgegeben, aber dann quasi noch diese Madagaskar-Pinguine hinten drauf geballert. Das gefällt mir nicht. Was ist denn eigentlich das für ein Typ hier? Wer denn? Hier wird noch jemand in einem Hemd, irgendwie hinter den Zeilen. Das ist Benedict Cumberbatch. Scroll mal runter, scroll mal runter, das ist Benedict, ach so, nee. Es ist auf jeden Fall Benedict Cumberbatch. Was er mit Tee zu tun hat, außer seiner britischen Herkunft, kann ich auch nicht in Gänze sagen. Ach da, tatsächlich, es ist Benedict Cumberbatch. G er mit T zu tun hat, außer seiner britischen Herkunft, kann ich auch nicht in Gänze sagen.
Ach da, tatsächlich, es ist Benedict Cumberbatch. Gibt es eine Beziehung? Naja, Brite. Aber es ist jetzt deutscher Subreddit für T. Also ich bin nicht in Gänze am Start, was jetzt diese visuellen Entscheidungen angeht. Also ich kenne die Verbindung Benedict Cumberbatch und Pinguine, weil es gibt eine legendäre Tierdoku, wo Benedict Cumberbatch den Offtext drüber gesprochen hat, so hier sehen wir den Pinguin und so und da geht es um Pinguine ausserhalb der Eiswelt und da hat er im Laufe dieser Doku immer mal wieder ein wenig Schwierigkeiten, das Wort Penguin auszusprechen. Und er hat verschiedene Arten, dieses Wort auszusprechen, die alle nicht richtig sind, aber alle sind in allem sehr niedlich. Ich glaube, wir haben Penguins, Penglings, und es ist sehr schön. Da könnt ihr auch auf YouTube euch einen Zusammenschritt anschauen, schreibt einfach Camerbatch, Penguin findet ihr reichlich, ist sehr cool auf jeden Fall anzuschauen.
Warum hat er keine zwei Takes?
Anscheinend auch so ein großes Problem,
dass hier der Regisseur nicht
in der Lage war, diesen Fehler zu korrigieren.
Aber da, glaube ich, könnte die Verbindung
Penguin-Cumberbatch
herkommen, wo jetzt die Verbindung
Pinguin-Tee herkommt, ist unklar.
Naja, Madagaskar, der Film Madagaskar.
Und die Pinguine trinken Tee, oder wie? Auf dem Bild. Okay. Ich glaube, das reicht. Aber es gibt mittlerweile auch tatsächlich verschiedene Kategorien. Also wir haben immer Kategorie Pfefferminztee, Kategorie Fruchttee, Schwarztee, Teesetup, Showcase haben wir auch einmal. Dann haben wir Rant. Der Stevia Rant. Der Stevia Rant. Dann haben wir Discussion. Und also es gibt verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Da gibt es auch schon so Markierungen für die einzelnen Posts, dass man das so direkt sehen kann, worum es geht. Also sehr, sehr schön. Das entwickelt sich gerade. Aber die Frage ist, wie stabil ist die neue Regierung? Oder rollen da nicht irgendwann neue Köpfe? Ja, aber man muss dem Ganzen auch ein bisschen Zeit geben. Weil nach so einem erfolgreichen Putsch und so, und der hat sich jetzt ja auch, der war blutig und hart geführt, ist glaube ich jetzt auch einfach ein bisschen Ruhe und erstmal ankommen angesagt. So ein bisschen, was machen wir hier eigentlich? Ich meine natürlich, Schritt drei bei einem Putsch kann natürlich auch immer sein, abwarten und Tee trinken, erstmal entspannt runterkommen, gucken, was passiert, wer sind so die Figuren, die sich rausarbeiten, wer sind
die neuen Anführer. Erstmal das
Ganze, glaube ich, drei Minuten ziehen lassen
und dann gucken, wohin geht das
Ganze. Oder halt vergessen, dass es, was
man es gemacht hat und am nächsten Tag
eine eiskalte, widerliche Plurre stehen haben.
Das kann dem Reddit auch passieren, das ist klar.
Ich bin ein, bin ich ein Rebell,
das könnte man so eine Frage stellen, bin ich
das Arschloch, könnte man machen im Tee-Reddit, wenn ich den Tee immer mit dem Beutel auftrinke? Ich interessiere mich in Scheiß für die vorgeschlagene Ziehzeit, ich mache einen Teebeutel rein, mache Wasser drüber und dann nach der vorgeschriebenen Zeit trinke ich den Tee, weil ich denke mir, ja, aber jetzt kann es ja nur noch geiler werden, weil nur noch dichter, nur noch mehr Frucht. Das heißt, der Tee wird im Laufe der Zeit sogar zwei Faktor intensiver, weil einerseits das Wasser weniger wird und die Ziehzeit länger wird. Das heißt, das ist ein Riesenspektrum. Aber Achtung, Curveball, die Hitze nimmt aber ab, dadurch wird weniger extrahiert aus dem Beutel, würde ich mal behaupten. Haben wir insgesamt jetzt also, wie ist der Faktor? Ich glaube, ein Strich. Ist es wirklich ein Strich, meinst du, dass sozusagen die fallende Temperatur sich ausgleicht mit der Ziedauer? Ich glaube schon. Und ich glaube auch das Verhältnis, also da könnt ihr gerne mal Graphen basteln, wie genau die Ziehverhältnisse aussehen dann so. Das ist, glaube ich, ein bisschen unklar. Und was ich jetzt für mich entdeckt habe, ist O-Long-Tee.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das richtig ausspreche.
O-O-O-Long, glaube ich.
O-O-O-O-O-Drei, vier, fünf O's.
Gibt es nur ein Reddit, wo man sowas fragen kann.
Eben, und da wollte ich mal fragen, wie spricht man das aus, weil das ist ganz toll.
Das ist ein richtig toller Tee, der schmeckt dann so richtig so buttrig, sahnig, toffeehaft.
Und ich finde den so lecker, O-Long-Tee, habe ich hier im Kölner Tee aus, habe ich mir das
gekauft und den kann ich nur
empfehlen, probiert das mal aus, wenn ihr das noch nicht kennt.
Und dann aber gehst du auch so weit, den Teebeutel in den Mund
zu nehmen und auszusaugen? Das hat keine
Teebeutel, das ist loser
Tee, so kleine Blüten, die sehen aus,
ich bin auch beim O-Long.
Das Bonbon, ich nenne es das Bonbon,
dass du am Ende nochmal den Teebeutel in den Mund nimmst
und nochmal aussaugst. Es wird ein bisschen draufgebissen auch. Ja klar, natürlich. Wäre vor dem Moment, wo der dann aufplatzt und alles im Mund ist. Oh ja. Wäre. Wäre der Moment. Wäre. Man sollte vielleicht weniger sprechen. Absolut. Ich glaube auch, wir haben es übertrieben mittlerweile. Aber ihr findet jetzt auf jeden Fall ein neues Zuhause in dem Separated Tee. Ich sag mal so, ist unsere Hunger gestillt?
Naja, ich finde, du hast hier ein ganz tolles Beispiel gefunden für, und ich finde wirklich, dass wir recht haben, rückblickend auch.
Klar war zu hart geführt, aber die deutschsprachige T-Community ist, glaube ich, grösser als die nischige T-Shirt-Zelebration, die da stattgefunden hat in diesem englischsprachigen Subreddit. Ja. Und dann gibt es ja auch wahrscheinlich ein T-Shirt-Subreddit. Und es gab halt keinen deutschen T-Subreddit. Und deswegen finde ich, das konkrete T-EE sollte, finde ich, ein deutschsprachiger T-Reddit sein. Und deswegen finde ich es gut. Ich bin jetzt mal ein bisschen weiter gesurft. Okay. Und zwar auf der Subreddit Gift. Nee, und jetzt, nee, jetzt verlierst du mich. Weil, nee, du bist das Gift, doch das Gegengift. Okay, ein Christina Stürmer Subred Reddit rauszumachen, bin ich am Start. Gibt es Reddit-Stürmer? Reddit-Stürmer. Heieiei, es gibt ... Oh nein. Gift ist tatsächlich, kommt man nicht rein, ist eine geschlossene Community. Ich weiß nicht, worum es in Gift jetzt genau geht. Request to join. Nein, da join, schaue ich jetzt mal rein. Meinst du, es gibt Giftmischer? Oder es ist Geschenke, Subreddit, einfach für süße Geschenke und damit die Beschenkten... Es ist nämlich Gifts. Gift an sich ist ja albern. Also Subreddit Geschenk ist ja auch komisch, wäre ja auch komisch. Ich stelle mir vor, dass du da jetzt... Ja, stimmt, Gifts. Unique Gift Ideas for your loved ones. Zwei Punkte. Du hast gerade bei der Community Gift, die geschlossen ist, auf Join geklickt. Ich stelle mir gerade vor, dass wenn man das überträgt ins Real Life, hättest du an so einem grossen schwarzen Turm oder so eine alte Mühle, hättest du so an diesem schon gerosteten Ring draussen mal angeklopopft und innen drin hörst du die Stimmen verstummen. So ein blubbernder Kessel im Hintergrund. Auf jeden Fall, oben aus dem Schornstein steigt grüner Rauch auf, du fragst dich aber nichts, weil dir ist schon klar, uiuiui. Ich bin hier für Geschenkideen. Du bist da für Geschenkideen. So und dann hörst du so Stühle knarren, entfernen sich vom Tisch, so, da war man am Tisch.
Roben, rascheln.
Roben, rascheln, Haare knistern.
Und dann kommt da jemand. Sklaven, keuchen.
Sklaven, keuchen.
Dann kommt jemand rein und sagt, hi, kann ich irgendwie helfen?
Ja, hi, ich such für einen Kumpel von mir, der hat jetzt nächste Woche Geburtstag und wir wollten so eine gemeinsame Party machen. Leute, wir haben wieder einen Geschenketyp hier. Ich weiß, ich weiß. Nein. Nein. Okay. Geschenketyp, ja. Genau, nee, ja. Ja, alles klar. Haben Sie einen Moment? Also, wir überlegen jetzt gerade, ob wir jetzt gemeinschaftlich was kaufen oder nicht. Also wie ist das, wenn man, kann ich jetzt was teurer, ich habe ein schönes Geschenk, das war zu teuer. Ja, wir haben ein schönes Geschenk, dieses Reagenzglas mit dieser opaleszierenden Farbe. Er ist tatsächlich wissenschaftsinteressiert. Was ist das? Das ist tatsächlich Hühnersperma. Oh, okay. Ist das so eine Art Delikatesse? Das ist eine Delikatesse. Kann ich mal probieren, Schluck? Ja, aber stellen Sie sich dann lieber aufrecht hin. Oh, ja, bitter. Spüren Sie was? Wenn Sie mal Ihre Arme auf und ab bewegen, spüren Sie, dass Sie ah. Sind das Federn? Ja, das sind Federn auf meinen Armen. Leute, es klappt. Tod, dann war er, war er tot. Dieses Hörspiel wurde präsentiert vom Deutschen Hörbuchverlangen. Vom Deutschen Reddit-Verbund. Uns geht's finanziell nicht gut. Wir haben Probleme und deswegen haben wir ein PayPal-Konto eingerichtet, wo sie den Deutschen Hörbuchverband unterstützen können. Ja, wir wissen nicht wohin, in welche Richtung es gehen soll, Hörbuch. Das Hörbuch ist tot. Wir sind an einer Weggabelung. Wir sind bereits an mehreren Weggabelungen falsch abgebogen und stehen jetzt vorm Abgrund. Vielen Dank. Vielen Dank, das war es. Hier die Credits Sprecher, Thorsten Wiemann. Aufnahmeleitung, Thorsten Wiemann.
Als Thorsten Wiemann.
Ich finde das alles toll, dass es geklappt hat.
Es könnte die nächste Hörerschaftswelle übrigens sein.
Giftmischer?
Nein, die Leute, die durch den Deutschland-Reddit,
durch unsere Übernahme auf uns schlossen.
Ach so, ja stimmt, herzlich willkommen.
Ist das ein neuer Grad Hörer?
Genau, meine ich. Oh, das neuer Grad Hörer? Genau,
meine ich. Oh, das müssen wir aber auf Puffopedia aktivieren.
Puffopedia Community,
da gibt es einen Post
zu den verschiedenen Hörerkategorien.
Machen wir da jetzt echt einen auf, wir sind
gerade bei der
fünfzehnten Klasse.
Die fünfzehnte Klasse
wäre also alles ab letzter Folge, ab Mai 2023. Seitdem die vierzehnte Klasse sind alle Hörer, die seit dem Chat-Duell auftritt, am einunddreißigsten Mai 2017 hören. Also alle, die die letzten fünf Jahre angefangen haben zu hören, sind immer auf vierzehnter Klasse. Das Musical war kein ... Nein, nein. Und wir ... Nein. Du warst doch bei P.M. Krause. Nee, nee, nee. Nee, T-Reddit-Übernahme würde ich sagen, finde ich gut. Damit alle, die diese Folge zum ersten Mal gehört haben, falls das eure erste Folge Podcast-UFO war, dann seid ihr Hörer fünfzehnter Klasse. Ordnung, fünfzehnter Ordnung. Richtig. Sehr gut, okay. Das ist erstmal nicht gut, das ist nicht ideal, aber man kann darauf aufbauen. Aber es ist auch erstmal wertfrei. Richtig, aber es ist die niedrigste Stufe. Es ist die wertloseste Stufe, aber jetzt erstmal wertfrei. Ja, richtig. Sehr gut. Mein Auto gibt den Geist auf. Mein Auto, ich f auf seit meinem 18. Geburtstag, fahre ich das regelmäßig, in Köln dann nicht mehr so regelmäßig, weil man hier nicht so viel Auto fahren muss und ich generell auch nicht so viel Auto fahre, aber es ist jetzt auf, aufgefahren, es fällt auseinander und ich stehe jetzt vor dem Problem, dass ich das jetzt verkaufen möchte noch. Ich will kein Geld mehr reinstecken. Liebevoll das Tizemobil genannt, gibt jetzt seinen Geist auf.
Genau. Und das Spannende ist, dass ich jetzt jetzt verkaufen möchte noch. Ich will kein Geld mehr reinstecken. Liebevoll das Tizemobil genannt, gibt jetzt seinen Geist auf. Genau. Und das Spannende ist, dass ich jetzt vor so ... Ich musste in die Werkstatt. Und ich wollte es einfach möglichst unaufwendig bei mobile.de verkaufen. Weil es fährt noch gut, man muss jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen Geld reinstecken und so. Aber ich möchte das nicht mehr tun. Ich bin auch kein Bastler, ich bin kein, ich bin kein Auto-Nerd und sowas. Aber es ist auch nicht nötig, dass du das selber
machst, aber gut. Ja genau,
aber das Geld reinstecken wäre halt etwas,
was man machen müsste jetzt. Ich habe
auf dieses Auto keine Lust mehr und
wollte das jetzt verkaufen und dann musste
ich tatsächlich in so eine
Werkstatt, wo man dann mir ein Angebot
macht und sowas und ich hatte vor diesem Termin
richtig Angst, weil ich war so nervös, weil ich mich, weiss ich nicht, hast du nicht auch Angst vor dieser männlichen Talk, dieser, weiss ich nicht, dieser Maskulinität?
Ich meine, ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass es da gute Online-Angebote gibt, wo man perfekte Werkstätten für sich findet, aber es ist natürlich schon ein grosses Problem, dass man da nicht die richtige Werkstatt findet.
Ich höre die Gitarre gar nicht, ich weiß gar nicht, Aber ja, ich war dann auf so einer Website, wo man das dann verkaufen kann und da wurde mir dann so eine Werkstatt vorgeschlagen, bin ich hingedüst und dann war es aber nicht der Werkstattbesitzer, sondern sein Neffe. Und dann, wir haben uns gut verstanden, der übernimmt dann ab und zu mal so kleine Aufgaben da, ist jetzt aber nicht der mit der grössten Erfahrung und er hat mir auch gesagt, dass er was ganz anderes studiert und irgendwie jetzt Wirtschaftsingenieurwesen und so steht. Ah gut, okay, ich dachte jetzt, er will Tänzer sein und du bist da in so ein richtiges Familiendrama reingehaut. Er hat vor allem lange Fussball gespielt, fast Profi, wir haben lange darüber gesprochen, gut verstanden. Geil, so ein bisschen gedribbelt oder was? Ein bisschen gedribbelt, ein bisschen auf dem Parkplatz gespielt. Dann sind wir zusammen, ist er dann gefahren, eine Probefahrt gemacht im Auto, hat sich alles angeguckt und hat schon so ein bisschen jetzt so Erfahrung gesammelt, hat irgendwie seinem Onkel über die Schulter geschaut, aber ist jetzt wie ein großer Autofan, noch hat er viel Erfahrung und ich habe ja auch keine Ahnung von Autos, was dann dazu führte, dass danach sind wir danach wirklich in diesen Hinterraum gegangen und dann ging es um die harten Zahlen. Und ich glaube, er hatte dann die Aufgabe von seinem Onkel, der nicht da sein konnte, mich kommen zu lassen mit einem Preisvorschlag, was halt, glaube ich, einfach erfahrene Verhandler, Autoverkäufer so machen. Ich wollte das aber nicht, mein einziger Gedanke, da hinzufahren, war, ich will die kommen lassen. Okay, was ist eine Schachmatsituation? Hat uns das durch beide fehlende Kompetenzen zu so einer, ja, zu so einem Aus geführt. Es hat einfach zu so einem Stillstand dann geführt, dass wir uns beide eigentlich einigermaßen dann für so eine halbe Stunde angeschwiegen haben. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, ich fahre jetzt dann wieder, weil ich glaube, der wollte mir sehr wenig bieten für das Auto. Ich habe dann noch irgendwie so mega panisch dann einen Kumpel angerufen, der sich auskennt und auch eine Werkstatt hat. Und er hat gesagt, fahr einfach wieder. Und dann bin ich wieder gefahren. Jetzt ist das Auto wieder bei mir. Wow. Ich bin keinen Schritt weiter, es ist nichts passiert. Dann hat mir mobile.de dann, dass das Angebot gewesen wäre, super wenig, ich glaube wir wären auch nicht zusammengekommen, aber es war so merkwürdig, weil er ist nicht, er ist nur, sorry, in Anführungszeichen nur der Neffe. Nichts gegen Neffen, Neffen können wir lieben besser sein als wir. Wir lieben Neffen. Absolut, wir sind Neffenfreundlich sind Neffen-Fans, wirklich. Absolut. Aber er war jetzt nicht der kompetenteste Ankäufer für Autos. Ich war nicht der kompetenteste Verkäufer. Keine Ahnung, konnte ihm keine Frage beantworten. Und du hättest nicht einfach mal was auf den Tisch legen können, so, ja, mal mal mal 160.000. Doch, ich habe dann was gesagt, eine Zahl, und dann hat er gelacht. Und das war so, und ich dachte mir vorher, ja, ich war irgendwie nervös davor und dachte mir, ich kenne mich nicht mit Autos aus und das wird alles unangenehm und dann stellen die mir Fragen und ich weiß nicht, was das bedeutet und war dann so nervös und dachte mir, was das Schlimmste, was passieren kann. Aber es war dann noch viel schlimmer, weil dann habe ich eine Zahl gesagt und er hat gelacht und dann haben wir uns, wollte er sagen, nee, sag mal ehrlich und sage, nee, aber sag du doch mal. Und dann, es war so kacke, alles daran war so blöd. Das ist so geil, einfach so diese Patz-Situation. Ja. Das ist so, wie wenn nach einem Date niemand zuerst schreiben will und man einfach sich nie wieder trifft, obwohl man sich mag. Aber es ist einfach nur, weil beide die gleiche Strategie fahren und einfach dadurch nichts vorankommt. Und einfach so, nee, ich warte, bis der einen Preis sagt. Ich bräuchte mehr Vermittler. Ich kenne eine Person in meinem Umfeld, die nach Dates super enttäuscht ist, wenn die Person, mit der die Person auf dem Date war, sich zuerst meldet und sagt, ja, hat nicht so gepasst. Diese Person kommt mit der Rejection nicht so gut klar.
Okay.
Was dazu führt, dass die Person sich angewöhnt hat,
immer die erste Person zu sein, die schreibt, es hat nicht so gut gepasst. Okay.
Zu einem Grad.
Um dem anderen zuvorzukommen.
Aber zu einem Grad, dass ich finde, das ist viel zu früh.
Aber die Person kommt so schlecht mit dieser Zurückweisung klar, dass dann manchmal am gleichen Abend noch der Satz, es hat nicht so geklappt. Das ist hart. Was ich so schlimm finde. Aber es ist schon eine Situation, wo man schon merkt, es klappt nicht, oder hat er dadurch auch manchmal eine gut laufende Situation kaputt gemacht, weil er dachte, lieber sag ich ab bevor ...
Nee, es war jeweils immer,
weil diese Person wusste,
das wird nicht weiter.
Ich glaube, diese Person hat sich dadurch
nicht irgendwas verbaut.
Das kam nur zu früh.
Jetzt wird es hart,
aber dann habe ich auch diskutiert,
weil ich dachte, ich finde das viel zu früh
und das macht den Abend kaputt und so,
man sollte doch zumindest mal eine Nacht drüber schlafen. Und irgendwie, das lässt das Date ja auch rückwirkend anders aussehen, wenn so früh diese Absage kommt, denkt man, hol ich, das ist ja gar nicht gefallen offensichtlich. Auf der anderen Seite nimmt man aber auch früh die Hoffnung weg und das ist halt auch, kann ja auch was Befreiendes, Cleansing. Total, ich finde das gut, dass man dem anderen diese Aufgabe abnimmt und das sofort sagt, aber es stimmt schon, wenn das so wirklich fünf Minuten, nachdem man sich verabschiedet hat, einfach so, nee, du, das wird nix, so dieses Abarbeiten ist schon hart.
Gut, aber ich kenne auch Geschichten, wo es dann auch während des Dates am Ende war, ja, ist ja klar, dass hier raus jetzt nichts wird.
Und dann fällt auch von beiden so ein bisschen Druck ab, auch ganz, ganz schrecklich, aber ich verstehe, auch da kann man ja diskutieren, dass es vielleicht gut ist, das direkt zu sagen. Aber schwierig. Ich finde nur so eine Nachricht direkt nach dem Treffen so schlimm. Es ist schwierig. Es ist ja die Frage, wie viel Zeit, auch so nach einem Bewerbungsgespräch, so einfach zwei Minuten danach, nein, einfach so direkt oder nach einem Casting oder so. Man braucht schon so eine Leidensphase so ein bisschen oder Hoffnungsphase. Zur Bewerbung übrigens, vielen, vielen Dank für eure ganzen Bewerbungen. Wir haben aktuell nach Editoren, Editorinnen gesucht für etwas, was ansteht bei uns. Und da kamen super viele Bewerbungen rein, alle ganz, ganz toll. Vielen, vielen Dank. Wir brauchen keine Bewerbung mehr. Wir sind mega happy mit allem, was reinkam, vielen, vielen Dank euch, es ist mega geil, was da alles kam. Vielen Dank. Vielen, vielen Dank, es war cool, sich das alles anzuschauen. Wir haben eine coole Community, merkt man immer wieder, dass da dann doch Leute auch dahinterstecken, die was können. Es ist mega geil, es ist super, bringt mich aber auch dazu, dass ich denke, vielleicht muss man sich ...
Also, vielleicht bin ich jetzt noch nervöser bei Aufnahmen.
Ach so, okay, dass da Leute zuhören,
die wirklich Ahnung haben und nicht einfach nur ...
Ich dachte, es wäre eine dusselige, graue, dumme Masse.
Ja.
Aber kommt raus, die haben Namen.
Die haben coole Namen.
Ja, also das muss man echt lassen.
Die haben Ahnung.
Verdammt coole Namen, ja, das stimmt schon, ja.
Hey, vor allem coole Namen. Da waren richtig coole Namen dabei. Die wohnen in coolen Orten mit coolen Namen. Die Ortsnamen. Die Postleitzahlen. Boy, oh boy. Wow, wow, wow. Das lief richtig gut. Deswegen bin ich jetzt sehr nervös. Da muss man aufpassen, zu dem man spricht. Ja, das stimmt. Aber wir können euch vieles bieten, wie zum Beispiel neue Wörter, die wir zum Beispiel einführen können. Oh, okay.
Zum Beispiel ...
Hoffentlich hast du was vorbereitet, ey.
Also man könnte ja zum Beispiel sagen, wenn man sich so aufeinander zugeht und dann geht der eine links und der eine rechts oder so. So und dann macht man so ein bisschen rum, hin und her und dann dauert das ein bisschen und dann könnte man das ja nennen, so den so, dass man den Tragee. Tragee, genau, dass man sich trajiert. Richtig trajiert und so könnte man ja vielleicht so als Treffwort reinnehmen. Für, wenn man jemanden sieht, der einen zuwinkt und die Person meint aber hinter einem jemanden. Der hat sich verwunken. Man winkt peinlich zurück. Man hat sich verwunken. Ah, ist mir zu einfach. Ja? Nee, weil man kann es ja für mehr Sachen merken. Du willst ein eigenes Verb haben. Ich war gar nicht gemeint. Es ist eher so, nicht nur diese Wink-Situation, sondern generell, jemand ruft in deine Richtung und du reagierst darauf, bist aber gar nicht gemeint. Das ist generell, du bist gar nicht gemeint, dafür ein Wort. Ja. Trage.
Ja, okay, ich mag, dass wir versuchen,
mehr Französisches reinzuholen.
Das finde ich schon mal eine Falle.
Changiert. Changiert?
Ja, changiert ist auch ein tolles Wort.
Ich habe changiert.
Das klingt fast wie sowas Kochiges.
Ich habe mich richtig schon verjangiert.
Aber ich mag das ja eh so,
ich mag auch dieses Fingerzeigen auf sich selbst, so dieses Ich und dann... Und dieses Gesichtsausdruck, diese Augen und dann ganz weit auf.
Denk mir, wie sieht es so die andere Person aus, die auf einem Bahnhof sagt so, hey, hier hinten!
Und die ganze Reihe davor.
Siebzehn Leute umdrehen und auf sich selbst deuten und du so sechzehn Mal, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Du musst alle wieder ablehnen, du musst ständig wieder ablehnen und sagen, nein, nur du. Nein, und dann auch diese Wischgeste, dass sie aus dem Weg gehen sollen. Ich habe auch bei Becker letztens ein Brötchen gekauft, das ich nicht wollte, weil diese Kommunikation so hart gescheitert ist, einfach mit diesem Zeigen und dann das hier und es war einfach
locker einen halben Meter weit weg
und dann habe ich so nach links gedeutet
im Sinne von
das links daneben, aber
dann hat die Person gedacht, ich zeige auf was
Neues und dann ist sie ganz
woanders hingegangen. Das Schild,
du besitzt das Schild, wo drauf steht
vier Weltmeisterbrötchen zum Preis von drei.
Das hast du jetzt.
Es waren drei falsch, sie hat dreimal auf die falsche Sache gezeigt, bis sie gesagt hat, okay, ja, das stimmt. Ach, wie unangenehm. So ein komisches Doppelroggen, Brocken, Roggelbrockel, Ding, Bullshit. Und du bist allergisch gegen Roggen. Ich konnte wirklich eine Woche lang nicht richtig atmen. Doppelroggen. Und dann hatte ich irgendwie irgendwie so ein Doppelrocklinchen oder so einen absoluten Nonsensnamen wieder.
Und dann dachte ich mir, da bin ich noch in eine andere Bäckerei gegangen und habe es richtig gekauft.
Doppelrock.
Aber das ging nicht.
Du kannst, ich glaube, es ist wie im Wasser, weil diese gebogene Glasscheibe bei der Bäcker, die bricht halt das Licht.
Dann sehen die auch grösser aus oder kleiner aus?
Man sieht, alle Menschen sehen super lustig aus. Auf der anderen Seite stehen,end haben alle luberlustige, verzerrte Körper und jede Fratzen.
Das ist ja auch nicht geil.
Stimmt, wie sieht der Verkäufer uns mit so ganz breit gezogenen Körpern?
Ja, da so ganz dünne, breite Körper und oben wird so mega bärnig.
Ah, das ist ja fantastisch.
Man muss erst mal lernen, nicht mehr darüber zu lachen.
Ja. Und wenn du das geschafft hast, da gibt es so Übungsgläser, dann musst du erst eine Woche lang. Auch so mit steigender Stärke, also die werden erst mal leicht verzerrt und wenn man sich daran gewöhnt hat, dann weiter verzerrt. Genau. Weil das ist das Wichtigste von Bäckereifachverkaufskraft, sie nicht zu lachen, wenn da wieder so irgendwas reingewackelt, so Wackelpudding reingewobbelt kommt. Habt ihr vielleicht mal auf der Straße gesehen, das sind dann Leute, die merkwürdig Brillen haben. Genau, die sind auch unten gerichtet. Die sind unten gerichtet und wenn ihr diese Brillen seht, dann merkt, ah, das ist jemand, da wisst ihr jetzt Bescheid, das sind Bäckerei-Ausbildungen, Fachverkäufer. Damit man nicht immer lachen muss. Damit die nicht lachen müssen, wenn wir da rein wetzen mit unseren verzerrten Körperchen. Finde ich aber auch gut so Anti-Lach-Training, auch so wenn du Arzt bist oder so und dann irgendwie ... Ich hab mich verletzt bei einer Penispumpe. Sorry, okay, Entschuldigung, ich komm noch mal rein. Okay, komm Sie noch mal rein. Du hast dann immer so einen Probepatienten, die immer witziger werden. Immer so einfach so am Anfang so ein kleiner Schmunzler, irgendwie, ja, ein Vogel hat mir das Auge ausgepickt. Okay, gut, dann kommt jetzt der Nächste. So, und das ist dann die eigentliche Arztprüfung, dass du nicht lachen darfst, egal was passiert. Ja, es kommen immer bekanntere Comedians rein. Nach Ticketverkäufen, bekanntere Comedians kommen rein. Und dann hast du Heselbrugger da sitzen. Ja, sitzen. Ja, ich bin Frau Hammer und ich habe mir mit dem Hammer auf den Kopf gehauen. Dann lacht man nicht und dann kommt Applaus. Sie haben es geschafft, Sie sind Arzt. Das ist wie bei LOL, wo dann immer so der Buzzer angeht, wenn jemand lacht. Du sagst LOL? In der Welt da draußen sagt niemand LOL. Ja, ist schwierig. Bei LOL denke ich eher an League of Legends, aber okay. Nicht Laughing Out Loud? Laughing Out Loud? Nee, ist schwierig. Woran nimmst du bei Roffel? Tatsächlich an einen sich über den Boden wälzenden Menschen, der wirklich auch immer so sieben Drehungen nach links macht und dann sieben nach rechts. Und dann sechs nach links, wo er sich langsam bewegt. Langsam weiter bewegt. Also ich stelle mir nicht jemanden vor, der sich so einmal links, einmal rechts, sondern jemand, der wirklich auch Land gewinnt. Ja, ja. Also der wirklich lachend, da und dann wirklich so dreht, dreht,
dreht, dreht und dann aber auch wieder zurück.
Das stelle ich mir vor. Aber noch keine Sendung. Meine Mom hat jetzt
den Lach, den Tränen-Lachsmiley
für sich entdeckt. Oh, super. Und es ist so
weird, weil es passt gar nicht,
weil zu ihr, aber
es ist so lustig, weil der jetzt, ja,
sie hat gesagt, sie muss den jetzt benutzen, damit ihre Nachrichten
nicht zu trocken rüberkommen. Und es ist so lustig, wie sich dann Menschen diesen Zweidig aneignen, der bei mir schon besetzt ist, weil ich, man hat ein gewisse... Mit saulustig. Das ist jetzt saulustig. Saulustig, ja. Nee, saulustig ist der, der sich dann schon so zur Seite schmeißt, wo man so jegliche Kontrolle übers Gesicht verliert. Bei mir ist saulustig, ha ha. Oh ja, ha ha ha. Hi hi hingegen, Mittel. Aber mir merkt ihr, wenn ich mich richtig kaputt lache, dann vertausche ich manchmal, dann ist es nicht ha ha ha ha, sondern manchmal sind zwei Haas nacheinander. Oh, so ein großer Kontrollverlust, dass die Tränen, weil du so viel lachen musst, die Tränen auf dein Display tropfen und du gar nicht mehr richtig tippen kannst. Aber es ist so ausserrande Band. Kontrollierter Kontrollverlust, weil ich schreibe bewusst dann zwei Hs. Also ich baue diesen Fehler bewusst ein, um den Leuten als Dimmel zu sagen, ich brauche die Kontrolle über meinen HH zwei Finger, die auch die Tastatur schnellen verloren. Gibt's mal so ein B, so ein B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, B, verloren. Gibt sonst noch so einfallen.
Küsschen auf die Stirn. Küsschen auf die Stirn, haut rein und wir sehen uns nächste Woche wieder hoffentlich.
Macht's gut, bis nächste Woche. Kommt gut durch die Woche, tschau!
Tschüss, wir heben ab, macht's gut!